welcome back to the show let's get back
to the phone lines at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50
we'll go to our next caller from the 5
to 0 area code caller what's your name
and where are you calling from and feel
free to jump right into your question my
name is very calm calling from Tucson
Arizona and I just wanted to ask I saw
recently that Arkansas is executing 8
inmates and over a small time interval
what do you think the future of the
death penalty is in this country do you
think it will ever be abolished or do
you think it's something that's just
ingrained in our culture I have not
heard about that specific story I am
hopeful that the death penalty will be
abolished I think it is completely
unbecoming of a state government or of
the state of governments to be saying we
are going to kill people this goes above
and beyond the fact that you know 1 in
25 on death row is innocent and some
other percentage is also effectively
cognitively disabled and you know if you
look at a trend line I know it can
sometimes be hard to see the trends when
you're just you know living it but if
you look at a trend line more and more
states are abolishing the death penalty
so I hope that it ultimately will be
abolished completely and I'm cautiously
optimistic that it will okay yeah
because it is it's looking at some of
the statistics and it seems to be you
know hugely popular at like 62% in favor
like it's more popular than marijuana
which I thought was shocking I haven't
seen that poll or do you know about that
Pat I thought that it was less and less
popular over time the death penalty that
is well we know that at this point
marijuana legalization is more popular
than not I don't think the same is true
for abolishing the death penalty idea
and keeping it in place is more popular
that's from what I've seen okay yeah
anyway we'll look at the numbers I
remain optimistic because we're going in
the direction of more and more states
abolishing thanks for the call death
penalty always a very very important
issue glad glad that you raised it